[Musique]
si on peut imaginer comment c'était
pendant les promoteurs ubeto c'était
vraiment comme ça une faute directe
réflexion de ma communauté
c'était juste et mention complètement
libre des enfants qui jouent des adultes
qui vont et viennent du bruit sous fond
de musique classique
on est loin de l'ambiance habituelle
d'un concert de kent nagano expérience s
est creux et mention cru enthousiasme
sans fresnes c'était quand même quelque
chose à un sentir
l'orchestré symphonique de montréal se
pose dans le grand nord québécois pour
la deuxième fois en dix ans alors
qu'istres a pris du coffre cette fois
quinze musiciens de chanteurs une
narratrice est une tonne de matériel
pendant que l'équipe prépare la salle le
maestro fait la promotion du concert
dans les radios locales pu rencontre des
élèves ici à coups de joie qu il leur
raconte ce qui se constate au premier
regard cap nagano a l'impression de se
sentir à la maison l'air ambiant les
maisons simple et surtout l'esprit de
communauté et les uns saute sentiment
qu'on n'est jamais complètement sol et
c'est ça ce que j'ai senti d'un coup
droit alors pendant cette semaine qu'un
pneu gano a partagé ses histoires sa
musique et même sa baguette avec olic
[Musique]
la jeune inuit de 17 ans réalise ainsi
le rêve de sa vie elle l'avait vu il ya
dix ans dans son village et souhaité un
jour pouvoir vivre ce moment
les musiciens ne sont pas en reste eux
aussi participent en faisant découvrir
leurs instruments principalement celles
échanges culturels qu'on a avec les
communautés qu'on les aide qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est même
passionnant ce qu'on vise
pour le percussionniste c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir le kilo tic le
tambour traditionnel inuit grâce à la
chanteuse de gorge qui accompagnent les
musiciens dans ma performance j'utilise
un tambour traditionnel et je fais du
chant de gorge raconte akinésie or cela
va aider les enfants à trouver leurs
traditions cool et à les partager
300 autres dans la chambre d'hôtel c'est
l'heure de la répétition dans chaque
communauté
une artiste locale est invitée à se
produire avec l'eau est saine et
akinésie linda 22 ans s'est lancé avec
enthousiasme mois dernier pour un
orchestre ce sont plus de 10 personnes
qui jouent de la musique classique la
musique que l'on joue dans les films de
princesses entre 17 et 20 heures c'est
l'heure du concert la population arrive
tranquillement s'installe
mozart prokofiev du classique pour
commencer que ce soit à coude jacques
salles witt ou coup de jouarres apic la
salle est sous le charme
lorem un trade est finalement conflit un
rôle de ambassadeurs culturels et
naturellement d'être un bâtiment ça
commence à la maison je pense est
important de ne laisse pas oublier que
canada est très très riches montricoux
[Musique]